Almost two years ago, he was with me for most of the campaign.
He is a great friend of mine...
...and there he is back there.
So, that's Marcus' pop right here.
We always tried to figure out how Marcus got so big...
...'cause Jeff is not that big and his wife is even smaller.
Y'all people forget now,...
...but this team was not ranked number one until the end of the season.
That's perseverance, and that's thanks to the tone the coach sets.
He trains these guys for competitive excellence, as he calls it. On and off the field.
And in sports, as in life, your number may be called just once...
Oh, whose phone is that?
Is that one of the player's phones? 'Fess up.
All right.
Coach is gonna talk to you after... about not turning off your phone.
In sports, as in life, I was gonna say your number may just be called once...
...but I didn't mean it literally.
And coach makes sure that you're... they're ready when that happens.
I understand that a lot of times reporters ask Coach Meyer,...
..."What did you say to the team at halftime?"
But what I've heard is he doesn't usually have to say too much...
...because the leaders of this team step up and say what needs to be said.
So, there are guys like Percy and Brandon, and Louis Murphy, and...
...I understand there are a couple of comedians here, the 300-pound Pouncey Twins.
Where are they? Right there?
All right.
And then of course there's the quarterback, where's Tebow at?
There he is, over there.
Heisman Trophy winner.
That's what I'm talking about.
Everybody is gonna get a handshake afterwards, just relax.
Tim's an inspiration to so many.
A guy whose true strength comes not from the gym, but from his faith.
He says he puts faith, family, and academics above football.